right
good afternoon fellow councillors
members of staff
members of the public and media you
please remain upstanding for the council
prayer
almighty god grant to us all needed
guidance wisdom and judgment as we base
the tasks before us
and enable us now and always worthily
to discharge the sacred trust placed by
the people in our hands
if i could just remind you we're live
streaming so
everything that happens in here it can
be observed
by the wider public interest
welcome to those who are joining live
stream
by the way where do we look
i'm down the camera
i'll move those your worship the second
worship
moved and seconded there's a discussion
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye public forum we have david pottinger
welcome to the meeting
thank you mayor tim members of the
invercargill city council
i'm actually taking this opportunity to
offer you some words of encouragement
i see on the agenda there's an item
related to working
on working together and in particular
the
media protocol i was here last month and
i saw
what happened when it was revealed and
that was an interesting
journey and i heard lots of things being
said about
lack of freedom of speech the death of
democracy as we know it we all sorts of
things
and i find it interesting because i also
watched
when uh councillor lush
was up there standing next to yourself
and reading through
what constitutes i guess the oath that
he must
follow and i guess all the other
counsellors are followed
and one phrase struck me in particular
and that was
and i paraphrased here to act
in the best interests of the people of
invercargill
and in the prayer it even says the
sacred duty
and what i'm encouraging
the committee to do the council to do
over the next wee while is to remember
that
and hold that foremost in their actions
you are looking to act in the best
interests
of the people of indicagal now it's been
discussion as to whether you need a
media protocol i know it's part of the
thompson report
whether we need certain constraints
i've been talking to a number of rate
payers around here no doubt
you you have as well and and a lot of
people say to me
we shouldn't need these rules we should
rely
on the good sense and sensibilities
of the people we elected to the position
of leading the city and i happen to
agree
i think what happens is there are other
things that get in the road
and that's why i encourage the council
to think about the important thing that
you
have been elected here for because
in a couple of months in june there's an
important time coming up
the review of uh whether or not
the two extra learner gentlemen that we
have here
are needed now i'm sure they have other
things to do in their lives they
wouldn't be too
upset if they weren't needed after june
is that right mr mckinsey mr grant
that you could find other employment you
wouldn't be homeless wandering the
streets
and i would think instead of because
it's been budgeted for
close to three quarters of a million
dollars has been budgeted
for this exercise that's 30 dollars per
each rate paying property and if you
said to people out there hey
30 dollars to have these guys they're
very nice people but um
if that was more like 15 or 16
then i'm sure the people of invercargill
would be saying hey
we're making progress we're doing well
they've both been involved with freezing
works and meat industries so they're
used to having changes of occupation i'm
sure
unlike some of us now i also saw the
council here
show a very empathic side when we were
talking about the increase in rents
to on the council owned properties and i
saw a very
good side of the council you were caring
about people
so all i'm saying is i encourage you
when there is discussion
about what is needed to get the council
back on track what is needed
to make sure the department of internal
affairs is not frying into our business
is to make sure that the decisions are
made in the best
interests of the people of invercargill
now if somebody's worrying what
the demise of democracy looks like i've
got one word for you
tauranga do we want to go there
do we want to be seen in that position i
don't think we do i don't think you do
i know many of you i've known you for
many years i've known one of you for all
his life
i mean i know you don't want to be there
i don't know maybe i'm i'm
acting the part of the of the the good
angels sitting on one shoulder saying
hey guys do what's right it's in the
oath
it's in the prayer and all i'm saying
is we of invercargill rely on you 13
people
to help lead us to guide us
we have faith in you so please remember
that
and i do encourage you to behave as i
know
you can so i just want to take this
opportunity thank you very much
your worship and i appreciate that
thank you any questions mr pottinger
well thank you very much for your
encouraging comments and uh
we do see the bright side of council
very often and it's
certainly we're undertaking some major
tasks in the near future
so we appreciate your support
thank you for the opportunity
interest register any changes counselors
no being none receiving the confirmation
of minutes
uh oh got another screen here
minutes all right that's just our
processors
[Applause]
meeting of council of the 23rd move
those your worship
thank you it's been moved second
moved and seconded in discussion
questions
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
i
carried minutes of an infrastructural
services committee meeting held on the
2nd of march i will move those you
worship
i've seen them you worship thank you
it's moved and seconded
questions discussion put it to the page
all in favor say aye
aye against carried minutes of the
performance policy and partnerships
committee held on the 9th of march happy
to move those your worship
second your worship moved and seconded
discussion
questions put it to the vote all in
favor say aye aye
carried the report of the
proposed road name change in relation to
the subdivision of 360
bainfield road
that council adopts the following
proposed road name the proposed road
lots 360 be named highland
rise as it is the developer's preferred
name
and meets the council's naming
conventions
i'm happy to move that recommendation
your worship
i'll second that your worship moved and
seconded
any discussion questions
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye convinced
carried
now we move on to item 7
on my screen
consider the items on the public agenda
the report of administrative matters
mr pete thompson will be here to
speak of the yeah welcome to the meeting
thank you your worship good afternoon
councillors
this uh report with the election of
councillor marcus lush puts council in a
position
where it can now determine appointments
to the various committees
subcommittees and other organizations
that have vacancies
as a result of the resignation of
council of middle
so this report outlines councillor's
current positions on the various
committees
and recommends councillors to fill the
vacant positions which are noted in red
text
i'll take the report as reading happy to
take any questions thank you
any objections considerations
all right update
uh for from project governance group
on the screen in front of us we've got
um
items from a to h well there's sorry
your worship um
if i can kick the kick things off i'm
happy to move the three recommendations
recommendation two which includes items
a to h dealing with the uh the name
counselors for
appointments and just noting that there
is still a vacancy if a council wishes
to fill
uh for an alternate on waste net
thank you for that
did everyone hear that all right one two
and three that's right
i'll see you in the moment
mr thompson if you've got yeah sorry
cancer cracker
thank you worship um if there are no
nominations or um self
appointments expressions of interest for
waste net might i suggest that we have
all of council as an alternative
alternate in which case darren
or myself or councilman ludlow or myself
are not available
councillor arnold is already an
alternate there's a vacancy for another
one and there's a vacancy for a second
count to the pattern i think you worship
yeah look since i'm
chair of infrastructure i think i could
put my name forward as an alternate
i mean it's a rare occasion i haven't
seen many uh 10 years i've been here
that
the alternate being used since uh
council arnold is first alternate
um i'll be second alternate
i'm happy as the mover for the motion
you worship to include councillor
pottinger as the ultimate
second alternate for wasting comfortable
without your worship
as the chair any further discussion
questions mr thompson is that all right
with you
nothing further from your wishes i'll
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye against carries
it's through any uh oh
that's my world
report on working on working on working
on working together uh
update from project governance group
presented by
mr jeff grant thank you worship is it
okay if i do it from here
yes thank you so this is
the second report in terms of the
governance group
to the council there are six
recommend five recommendations and one
for noting
in terms of the progress so i'll just
briefly
run through them the first one is just
that in order for the governance group
to
work in a sensible way of seek to have a
alternate for each of the members on the
governance group which are listed there
under one
the chairs group which is chaired by
lindsay mckenzie
has got the attachment a which is the
appendix
sitting out in terms of reference for
cheers group then
under number three is the revised
debrief for the working group the
strategic projects and supporting the
ltp
this is a reflection on that particular
working group
that the view was that the progress on
the ltp
both in the workshop process and both in
the staff information and everything
was well on track and so what the ltp
progress will be for this working group
is to look at a review
post the ltb process
and look at setting up a mechanism for
the next ltp
and in the triangle so this is looking
forward in terms of making sure that the
process is well uh governed
going forward so that's the change
that's been made and recommended by pgg
for that particular working group
and then there's just the updated
framework for
an appendix c and then on
six which is the set out for the
methodology and timing for
evaluating progress against the report
so we'll
pg g you will have heard for those that
were at the risk
and all committee risk and assurance
committee meeting yesterday with some
discussion
in terms of the um external advisors
report
that we would frame up for
pgg a slightly more
formal framework in terms of the
reporting um but also
here and six was that um there will be
an evaluation process to measure against
that
uh in terms of the progress and that
will set out
in a range of
things including the workshop that i o d
survey
just in terms of the budget there's a
comment around the budget let's say that
the 310
000 allocated for all of this work is
well
under that and looks to will track well
under the cost of the 310
by the 30th of june
just a couple of other matters that are
not directly
related to that firstly is that the
progress around the draft
charter well mentioned uh is the
intention that
that will come back to council uh as
soon as
the draft is finalized and we'll
probably look at it
just having a workshop to finalize that
off and on the basis of that
lindsay and i have both expressed an
interest that we would have a council
group uh just the councillors we'll sit
down we'd like to have a discussion
about
where we've got to so far what bits are
working in terms of
our involvement and what bits the
councillors may want to see
through to the period of 30th of june so
we'll look at trying to do that as soon
as possible
in the very near future so your worship
that
saw any questions will thank you all the
recommendations would be good
questions counselors
well there be none i'll put it we've
moved it in a second version
oh counselor sorry i didn't see you i'm
happy to move the recommendations your
worship
thank you i'll be having a second
discussion questions life
thanks your worship um look thanks jeff
for the report and for the work that you
and and lindsay are doing for us and and
with us
um i take on board uh
your suggestion that we have a
counsellor-only
briefing um i think it would be useful
from our perspective
the sooner that we could we could do
that the better can ask how much
time you would need to lead him before
being able to oh
i can do it tomorrow um 45 minutes and i
think we just need about 45 minutes you
know how many days you would need
to prepare for it because essentially
we've got uh two extraordinary meetings
of ppp and infrastructural services on
monday
i think if but we have a look at william
fitz and we
are happy to do it next week yep
i think i'm like you i think lindsey and
i would be keen to do it sooner rather
than later we're just starting to look
at it
prioritizing around phase two and um
we'd like to
raise a couple of issues with you in
that discussion as well
thank you any further questions
counselors
well we certainly appreciate your input
yeah mr grant
move on
i'll put the motion all in favor say aye
aye
against carriage news reports being
tabled
and just covers some topical issues
that we're dealing with like three
waters
i'll put it to the boat oh sorry i was
going to move your worship that we
received
your report your table report thank you
singing moved in second any discussion
the questions
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
items of urgent business
raise this part
yes it's not particularly urgent but i
just like to make a statement
to thank the staff for all the work
they've been doing over the last few
months
um sometimes that goes unheralded i
think some of them were extremely long
hours
and i'd just like to formally say that
we all appreciate the amount of work
that's going on behind the scenes
thank you thank you for that
any items under that remove
all right well we've come to the part of
the agenda
where the um
public are to be excluded and thank you
very much for your presence
here it certainly helps um
to see who we're actually dealing with
i'll move that with the exception of
jeff grant and lindsey mckenzie that we
go into public excluded your worship
i'll share that your worship thank you
moved and seconded in his discussion
put the vote on in favor say aye